welcome to this video coverage for round
nine of the candidates tournament and
this is about the game of the shared
Charlie bleeder former world champion
vishy anand playing wrestling top Allah
from Bulgaria who's on minus one score
at the moment um yeah let's see how this
game went down Yung on a plane a form
and topple Ava's going for the night off
is not trying to do anything out of his
normal opening repertoire it's been a
night of player form for ages of course
they they both know a great deal about
it as they have played it with both
sides numerous times wishes main opening
against you for s also the night off and
double king born of course he 45 and
what is really playing here yes the new
main line welcome to the new main line
of the night off h3 um yeah I've talked
about it in other videos and well it's
it's it's good to do something a little
bit unexplored the power plays e 6 which
is some of course very decent choice
black claims that a tree is a pretty
pretty slow setup and since ok I'm going
to set my pieces up in a typical evening
and night of ravening type of way people
enjoy my tries at Dutch pronunciation ok
rg4 and black is retreating yes sort of
voluntarily to d7 bit strange looking
but it's not a bad move at all this
night is simply am avoiding this this
kick and like would set up a perfectly
normal position here 96 and now h4 yeah
why does some and
on the on the King side yeah what about
the pollen on edge for ya if black takes
it what will gladly take this important
central pawn in exchange for that and
yeah this is a fantastic position for
white black cannot take the pawn here
played tonight d to e5 and wish you just
pushed with g5 of course yeah well White
has gained space on the on the King side
and very much discouraged black from
castling short just like that I think a
move like castles and this position
would really be quite dangerous for
black I mean I guess white will probably
play Queen to e2 and then Castle long
and then f4 it's not like white is
winning i'm not saying saying that but i
think that is certainly a position that
white players in the open sicilian would
very much like to play all this is a bit
slow on the queenside of like I mean you
haven't even gotten be five in the paula
was doing something else he plays Bishop
d7 first and delays castling for a
moment which i think is a pretty pretty
good decision um he also could have
thought about 90 for him after which
white will probably retreat this looks a
bit weird at first this retreat but one
possible idea even could be be three and
Bishop b2 here the Queen side here
Jethro is quite often a pretty good
setup if white as tends to Castle long
as it also lends some protection to the
King night c4 was interesting but not
anything well decisive in a way he
decided to play Bishop d7 which is
perfectly okay I think
okay now I took on different on c6
Bishop takes yeah the bishop is nicely
place now and b3 it was just designed
this exchange on c6 to now clarify
matters white wants to have control over
c4 and later move the Queen and castle
wrong um in this position if white tries
to cover this square by the normal
looking Queenie with Queenie to there is
b5 and not c4 is really quite annoying
here note that now b3 is really
weakening the queen is just wrongly
placed him and others move is stronger
he plays b3 immediately and if now black
tries to use this somewhat loose night
with Queen a5 he can protect the night
with something like 22 and then go for
long castling pretty normal position I
think yeah in this position actually
tapar love played the very interesting
concept oh sorry I forgot a line I
forgot alone Queen 85 Queen d2 there's
actually the move d 5 which I wanted to
show intending bishop before this is
quite good for black I am I misread my
notes yeah this isn't a pretty cool cool
idea
and now even this black is an excellent
shape yeah wyd retreats this is more
than excellent shape now 22 is actually
a bit of a mistake you need to go here
it looks a bit passive but what is
immediately threatening 95 saw the Queen
needs to move again and then something
like that is probably going to happen
with the long castles to follow then
typically complicated to the soul Ian
middle game which was something that
could Apollo could have gone from he had
a different idea he played them with f5
which is quite surprising to me it looks
a bit unconventional to do that but yeah
it's maybe not it is maybe not so bad
really it's just it just feels a bit
strange in my book to push f5 and if I
read this correctly wish he was also a
bit critical about the move but I'm not
so sure how it develops in the game is
this is so terrible for black um okay i
think what right is doing now is it's
pretty straightforward he played f for
taking this night night g form and Queen
to e2 covering on e3 this Bishop yeah
what black is trying to do with their
fathers pretty much in sort of a
preemptive strike on the King side so
you don't get attacked so hard he wants
to clarify the situation in the center
and here like even gets the the bishops
but one problem is that this Bishop one
is heaven is always limited by this pawn
wedge and how is black actually going to
to activate species now he took on e for
Dwight canceled long yeah I think now
the next move was also quite okay lady
five
and our laundry captured on e4 yeah look
at this position it's a very interesting
position from a strategical point of
view um we have this pollen center so
black e 6 and d5 this um can arise also
from another opening and it's pretty
clear what I'm talking about it's it's
from the French the French defense you
sometimes get this type of structure and
there are various various nuances for
for this structure quite often you have
it with the white pawns not like this
but with this pawn back on g3 f/4g three
sometimes h4 played sometimes its back
on h2 in this structure white typically
has quite a comfortable advantage
because he will always use this night
probably here only five and also Bishop
283 to pressurize it 64 this is very
colorful yeah well these points are weak
quite clearly and they can be attacked
easily Bishop to h3 as one of them to
attack here and the night might also be
regrouped let's say to deform attacking
you six can also loops I can also go to
e5 possibly or also to d3 in the French
as mentioned the pawn is often on g3 so
there is no counter play on f4 this is
the difference in this position black
actually if we look at this chat later
this check to not so sure off to be
honest but what black needs to do he
needs to try to get enough counter play
here I believe against the d6 against
the f4 pawn this is black zone d
counterplay really he needs to try to
balance or to find some kind of counter
play as compensation
provides play against them against three
pawns Bishop a3 is maybe not the most
precise way to play um I actually looked
at um what was it castles right castles
and if we now and not one hundred
percent sure what White's most precise
move order is but let's say white is
trying to regroup the night to d3 maybe
not the most precise way to play i'm not
i'm not quite sure let's say here
attacking here note that if white takes
a here you don't really have a great
great option F for as hanging if you
cover it there is this check check ruki
aid and black gets very active it's a
quite often if you take the weakness
that you play against at the wrong
moment then you sometimes give away the
whole initiative here black even has
Queen c3 coming with the possible made
later let's not take here play good move
play 93 to to cover their form weakness
you still have the pressure on e6 yeah
now loopy eight let's say King B 1 and B
should be six something like that could
be a setup that black can actually play
trying to get enough counter play here
and operating with small technical
tricks to actually let you six yeah be
unprotected for a couple of moves maybe
black in with some line like that can
still get a play will position night f2
what I played here in my sample line
it's probably not even a very precise
move as you don't really need to move it
at the moment and it's not clear yet if
this is right this is correctly timed at
the moment there are other possible
of course you can consider that for
example Sark win a five maybe now
attacking the knight and attacking here
okay what if I go King be one first
maybe this one yeah it's tricky I mean I
think that this is a better defense than
what Apollo did you get a check which
forces a move king be one that right
wants to play anyway and after Queenie
79 f 2 I played Bishop c5 here here
black also could go for this type of
setup that I showed before with the
attack on f4 it's only a couple of moves
down but yeah maybe still this was an
alternative something like that Jeff and
now it's already tricky to defend this
right may be here Jan it's not much fun
to play yeah I'm pretty sure so that the
pile of really hated the position he's
simply not the guy to defend in any way
passively he wants to always play active
moves which is in the very vast majority
of cases right strategy active defenses
almost always the right one but gap here
here it is tough to defend he played
Bishop c5 and just took on f2 which in a
way looks somewhat obligin to to clarify
the situation like that but on the other
hand black was banking on the fact that
you gets a quick play against their form
but look at this Queen deform and rookie
one
it's all only six Luke f8 look everyone
king queen to d6 and now rookie five
white maintains a perfect control here
black still has the weak pulse the bad
bishop and the possible disadvantage in
space of this is a wrong wrong phrase
black has a disadvantage in space in
space on the King side and this might
even be a tricky factor in terms of the
King long-term white has an excellent
controller and to cut off try to defend
check with the exchanges very
understandable really as in this
position also the pawn on d6 is not so
exposed anymore to an attack by the rook
still of course white is always better
in this position it's just a matter of
um yam them the yeah how big that want
it really is is it just clearly better
is white I'm able to actually get to
winning position is it just slightly
better yeah it's probably a clear
advantage for white but it's still not
not so easy to kill off a 4 is typically
good move possibly intending a 5 to fix
more poems on light square Bishop v8 was
played and TF Allen played king between
in this position he probably had a
better move with the Queen a7 intending
just Bishop takes a 6 and this is in
fact not so easy to to to combat one
possible reply this Bishop takes a for
quite funny because the capture check
leads to perpetual check check but what
can simply take here and after that
claim that this has helped him I'm not
so sure if this is really the case white
is just very very better here
but he also had a great position in the
game and it's not really clear to me
that this wasn't any way better yeah
black could activate this Bishop but
it's a store long term sorry i played
this too quickly it's the long term very
tricky for black to play the pawns are
on light squares as mentioned and it
will be very tough to to play play the
position if you just form for one moment
consider what happens if we we have a
queen trade here if we would take off
Queens in this position white would have
a very simple plan to invade with the
king this is actually very tough to do
to to defend against white of course
needs to cover c2 before I does that but
this is just one possible problem with
the blacks position the invasion of the
of the king after Queen trade and
sometimes the scan can be initiated by
white entering l'exposition like a five
queen bee six before Queen to c5 yeah
it's it's really is really a grind where
black has to suffer and just mention to
par love is not the kind of person to
suffer passively in a position and
sometimes um he he tries to defend
actively where it is simply not working
and here we got one of those cases he
plates h6 and this is probably the move
that that definitely loses the game um
after that he probably is beyond saving
what takes and Queen g-form this is a
very very serious problem now Hank's
Hanks hmm okay there's just one move to
cover both and now white can push h5
yeah bishop moves and a five and this
now is too much to defend
this is a terrible weakness on age 6 e 6
is obviously still a point of a check
and with a five writers also fix these
pawns on light squares it's now probably
probably a lost position if you are give
it to a tour to an engine it's already
on plus two just to make clear that this
is not something something a little that
that white hassium and wish it does a
very good job here bishop age 7 and now
keep it simple c3 and c4 when the bishop
is only for so black cannot take yeah
he's simply gaining spatium black is
always tied to the defense of the six
bond if you try that you have just put
yourself in a very awkward pin on the
king yeah sorry this is actually what
was played sorry he actually played that
yeah I understand I mean what else is
there if you yeah you you cannot really
move anything right here yeah Queen move
okay I'm gonna check you and enter on f6
got a few pretreat here check we drop
the pawn yeah it's just the disaster of
a business position queena for ya now
check he took on a five with check check
check all this false will check its but
it's completely forced what should like
do if you go here check I actually
manage a queen trade and while this you
if you don't survive check
Dwight is winning very easily John do
you need to go to e8 check began this
check chant again with check so a very
very tough turn of events for to Paolo I
mean turn of events is a bit much EP was
worse anyway but it very quickly went
downhill yeah Queen here King to do 17
to d5 very dominating position of white
screen it covers the pawns and the text
the weakness and in fact White's King
which is the only cause for concern in
terms of a perpetual check happening is
relatively safe check yeah wyd users
that uses the king here check now
activated as much as possible and
actually the king is an attacking peace
now supporting the check together with
the Queen if black no takes here check
check we have this simple check way to
win yeah went to see seven and now queen
here this is serve again very simple if
it like takes check yeah black does not
have many moves queen d 6 is threatening
anyway check yeah possibly even going to
be 6 check
yeah and now there's the Queen trade
threatened and also those discoveries by
the king j yeah black really am has to
suffer here check and after e62 Paulo
resigned this just nothing left yeah
check check there is a counter check
well where do you go if you go somewhere
on the seventh I can't just do this
check and win with the queenside so a
very very smooth victory by Anand again
a game in which him didn't really make
any serious mistake or any mistake at
all the part of somehow stumbled into
this this structure which is somewhat
himself initiated with this at flatbush
and this I think is already very tricky
to play maybe there was some some better
setup I don't really think that black
should be lost here or anything but in
the practical game that they played he
simply couldn't find a defensive set up
that really keeps the position on
together I really believe that it starts
here this check this maybe not the best
way to go but down my my my intuition
tells me that what would have also had a
very good game if he if he does
something else it's just very awkward to
have those those weak points here yeah
to sum it up for the tournament another
win for on Artie's on plus three and has
excellent chances to win this tournament
I mean this is really this is really a
sensational tournament for him
if you look at recent years even ever
since yeah even before the World
Championship match in 2012 against
girlfriend even before that he really
has played very sometimes very
uninspired chess which really was
sometimes a pain to watch if you know
what he's capable of and he is really
playing a in an excellent fashion I mean
11 differences and this is certainly
true that in lots of those games where
his play looked very uninspired he also
got simply very uninspiring positions
right of the out of the opening those
terribly boring positions at times
especially with black and here you get
something that he can play with just
more complicated positions and if he's
uh yeah it seems that he is in good
shape and is very sharp in his own
calculation and yeah then then he can
still do great things I mean we are
looking at a player who was playing in
fantastically just a few years ago so
why shouldn't he be able to to do that
at least in this tournament I mean it's
not like he has unlearned Chesser in a
period of a couple of month so really
great performance by honored enter with
this score he has very good chances to
to qualify of course a very crucial game
will be the match against the game
against Kramnik where we have the where
we'll have the when you will have the
black pieces and yeah very very crucial
game I think actually if he survives
that you will probably do the job and
qualify yeah still one word on to pawn
off his on minus 2 now and it's really
out of it I mean you great optimist
could have thought okay if he wins this
game maybe
yeah but it didn't it didn't it didn't
happen he simply does not seem to be in
a in a great shape Ian and with minus 2
we will finish probably on the bottom
half of the table even at the end of the
tournament alright thanks for watching